rule number 11 do not bother children
when they are skateboarding that's a
very specific one there yeah yeah it is
well that's it that's an essay about
masculinity mostly you know I used to
watch kids skateboard on st. George
Street which is kind of cool because
obviously st. George is the Dragon
Slayer that's the street I work on which
i think is quite funny and anyways these
kids used to you know there are
teenagers young teenagers we have these
long bar hand railings going down some
shallow stairs but it's fairly good
flight of them and they would boardslide
down these rails it's crazy it's it's
concrete that's pebbled it's like you
don't want to land on that you've
probably heard a lot of bones crunching
oh it's like you know but and they
didn't have much protective gear on and
you know and eventually this university
put up things to stop them you know from
doing this which I complain about in
this chapter for a bunch of reasons but
like I liked watching those kids I like
watching skateboarders do those crazy
things because they're trying to become
competent like in there they're facing
danger they don't want the damn
protective gear like sometimes it's just
stupidity it's like wear a damn helmet
you know but sometimes it's not it's
like no I don't want to wear a helmet I
want to expose myself to this danger
it's not that I'm stupid maybe it is you
know I'm just being careless right but
maybe it's not it's like no I I'm facing
the danger I'm trying to master it and
if you watch kids board slide down like
handrails if you don't think that that's
courageous then you're and may be stupid
those two things aren't so easy to
distinguish yeah but it's brave and when
they do it it's like amazing it's it's
impossible to do that you jump in the
air you grab your skateboard you balance
on this stupid rail you slide for 20
feet and the you know the price for
failure is well you do the splits on the
rail that's not fun you know or you land
headfirst on that that's I can change
your masculine masculinity like yeah
yeah I'm so like and the kids are often
shooed away it's like wait a sec there
they're practicing being courageous
they're practicing mastering something
in the face of danger
you know and a lot of the rebellious
behavior of young men in particular
which is very frowned upon in the
schools it's like that's toxic
masculinity you know that horrid horrid
phrase mm-hmm it's like leave those damn
kids alone let them like another thing I
referred to in that chapter is about 10
years ago in Toronto they changed the
insurance rules governing the
playgrounds and parents had raised money
for these damn playgrounds so there's
nothing wrong with them they tore em all
out the whole city like two weeks before
school started there was nothing but
like dirt and gravel what happens aren't
rubber enough or they were bouncy enough
for there were two unsafe who knows
right who knows what there was nothing
wrong with them you know well then the
kids were I saw the kids on top of the
school so because they needed some
danger yeah we know that kids on
playground equipment they will push to
the limit of their ability that's what
you see what you like when you go see a
sport like gymnastics mm-hmm you know
you think you go see a gymnast and like
the gymnast does a flawless routine and
like everybody claps like mad you know
the judges say 9.9 and it's it's and
then the next person comes up and
they're screwed it's like 9.9 it was
basically perfect how can you do better
than perfect and then they do it and and
you can do better than perfect because
so the person is like they're on the
edge and they go out there and you know
you watch them you feel it in your body
because you're mimicking them
physiologically you see that everything
they do is that much farther out into
chaos than anything they've ever done
right they're pushing themselves to the
absolute limit of their ability and
everyone's like this because you tell
with every gesture that they're that
close to making a mistake and so they've
taken this courageous step beyond their
competence mm-hmm and put everything on
the line in that celebrate in that and
then when they land they land in a way
that's unlike perfect perfect plus and
everybody immediately leaps to their
feet and like to get a chill right and
it's the same chill your hair stands on
end it's the same chill that a mouse has
when it looks at a wolf the most puffs
up
and so what you've just seen is are
inspiring because you've seen someone
courageously move past perfection into
the unknown and and not only ennoble
themselves more but to a noble humanity
itself and upon your feet it's like yes
and then it's tens right it's tens they
win the gold and it's like well everyone
knows what that's like it's like a great
musical performance and that's that's
being in that place where everything
lines up it's better than perfect